I'm curious how you're doing during
lockdown as a person how are you
handling this experience of being locked
down I am worryingly fine I'm more
afraid of leaving lockdown this is I
didn't have any friends loads about 19
though I this my entire youth was locked
down I've been training for this my
whole life this is my Olympics I was
made for this moment I was born for this
weight you is this true you had no
friends until you were 19
it's just super super shy and incredibly
socially inept and so I just wasn't
great wasn't great with people
yeah yeah well I have my 12 I have my
special spot
yeah it's that's very good a few friends
of high quality is all needs I have
about eight friends a very low quality
so I've I've got the formula wrong and
if they're watching right now you know
who you are
I was excited because I heard that you
got a puppy is that was that because of
the quarantine you got a puppy do you
think that helped you make the decision
or no I think I always wanted a dog and
I've just never had times I've been on
planes and trains and automobiles I've
been moving around consistently and
knowing that I knew this wasn't going to
be three months I knew that this was
just gonna go and go and so I just
thought I'm gonna spend a year in my
house and I have no intention of picking
up any new skills really I this is the
time to become a dog parent and so I
have gotten a little cute horny ginger
biscuit in my house what is the dog's
name perrault I was going to name him
Barry because I like mundane human names
for animals and then a friend of mine is
so posh that she mistakenly thought that
fairy was short for Perrault which is an
infinitely Dhamma name I've never even
heard of the name barold is barold a
real name it's definitely not she talked
cause of Harry and Harold
that was her logical prediction and so
barold was the dummy named Harold is the
name that gets you bullied at secondary
school that's the name of its a
character-building name for a dog do you
do you think that works if you give
someone a strange name they're taunted
they feel humiliated and then they grow
into a stronger person talk show host
that was low that was uncalled about I
think you have a beautiful name I love
your name but I didn't think of that it
is it's Duran Duran yes so a dog is a
lot of responsibility are you handling
that all right I mean are there things
the dog is doing in quarantine that's
bothering you he's just it's just the
shocking the shocking and the biting
just the horny teenage vampire Riverdale
by night in my wait I think he's hot
started hunting at nine weeks old and
like I know that the kids are growing up
fast but Jesus Christ nine weeks old and
he's humping like crazy little pink
lipstick nine weeks okay first of all
blanket which we now call a ghost
which I shouldn't have said on this show
I'm sorry do I leave no you shouldn't
leave we'll just process what you've
said yeah I don't think you should refer
to Beryl's a little lipstick men don't
like that we don't like it when it's
referred to that way trust me okay take
it easy he's a good dog he just it's
it's a lot of responsibility but it's
incredibly fun and it's also this is
it's it's a weird time to get dogs you
can't socialize them so I'm worried I'm
going to have like a little aggro
phobic sort of politically incorrect dog
that is going to be afraid of all of the
people that don't look exactly like me
right right exactly
your because of the quarantine you're
raised you're gonna have a racist dog
that's what's gonna happen
yeah what does that party like they're
afraid of people wearing hats people
wearing masks everything so I have no
idea how it's gonna go I'm gonna age
very fast I can tell don't think so